ja wir alle werden ja seit 2016 durch
die ezb schleichend enteignet durch eine
historische nullzinsphase bekommen alle
kein geld mehr auf unserem sparbuch für
mich als schwabe ganz besonders schlimm
natürlich parallel sind wir aber
natürlich numero eins in bezug auf
schulden wir haben viele schulden
gemacht aber natürlich auch sehen wir
dass wir den höchsten strompreis haben
weltweit und wir sind auch in der
champions league wenn es darum geht
steuern zu bezahlen kein land kein
bürger zahlt mehr stören als in
deutschland und jetzt natürlich sind wir
auch auf 1 28 jahres hoch bei der
inflation 4,1 im
september das heißt wir alle verlieren
4% kaufkraft und es wird weiter voran
schreiten die ezb frau lagarde sagt war
das ist nur temporär und auch ökonomen
wie marcel fritsche sagen das ist nur
für 23 monate pustekuchen ich kann ihnen
sagen die inflation ist da sie wird
bleiben sie wird stärker werden die wird
auch nicht mehr verschwinden der winter
wird entweder extrem kalt oder extrem
teuer weil rohstoffpreise heizungs
preise energiepreise explodieren
momentan parallel haben wir eine politik
der letzten wahl programm oder zum
regierungsprogramm vorgestellt hat wo
ich mich frage wer soll das bezahlen wie
soll das finanziert werden und jetzt
sehen wir schon dass die das die
immobilien und auch die aktienmärkte
immer weiter steigen durch den laxen
notenbankpolitik - zinsen thron und ich
glaube einfach wir werden alle
schleichend enteignet bei installation
ist nichts anderes als eine versteckte
steuer der staat kann sich in schulden
wird sagen die steigende preise und das
ist sozialer sprengstoff die kluft
zwischen arm und reich wird immer größer
man muss jetzt anfangen wir sehen uns ja
auch nicht so einen immobilienpreisen
oder an den aktienmärkten die immer
weiter steigen und die reichen immer
reicher macht nein wir sind auch heute
historischer tag bitkom hat ein neues
allzeithoch erreicht die menschen
verlieren das vertrauen in das
geldsystem in die ezb und man muss jetzt
aktiv werden sonst werden in den
nächsten jahren alle schleichend weiter
enteignet die diskussion ist offen
friedrich ich muss ihnen leider recht
geben danke schön ja also ich sage mal
so weil das ist auch ein ganz ganz ernst
ist immer politiker neigen weltweit dazu
alle probleme immer sofort mit der
druckmaschine mit der gelddruckmaschine
zu lösen das kann auch gut gehen ja das
kann eine zeitplan gut temporär temporär
es ist jetzt ich habe mich gewundert
dass es schon so lange gut geht aber
jetzt ist das so exzessiv geworden ja
durch die natürlich auch durch die
pandemie aber ich bin ganz bei ihnen
wenn jetzt die ezb sagt das wäre die
inflationsrate würde sich ja auch bald
wieder nach unten bewegen ja das ist
zweckoptimismus tatsächlich ist es so
dass alle indikatoren eigentlich nur
eins zeigen die inflation wird länger
anhalten und heftig und sie wird immer
heftiger werden und jetzt möchte ich
natürlich hier jetzt keine ängste
auslösen weil engster auch nicht gut
sind aber die ganz nüchterne reale
betrachtung der wirklichkeit ist nicht
so wie es uns momentan die politiker
und natürlich auch die ezb ja wir machen
es uns uns aus den augen wischen reifen
haben die leider in diese widerspreche
für mich jetzt mal als politikerin
angesprochene runde
ich muss tatsächlich sagen ich sehe es
auch wir haben überall preis explosion
sie haben es eben gesagt wir müssen uns
aber auch die frage stellen woher kommt
eigentlich und der größte treiber dieser
extremen inflation ist im moment
tatsächlich der staat nämlich natürlich
durch extrem hohe steuern wir sind ein
steuer hochland wenn wir uns die
steigenden energiekosten angucken knapp
50 prozent davon sind steuern das heißt
eigentlich müssen wir uns auch da die
frage stellen dürfen wollen wir nicht
eine inflationsbremse einführen um das
ganze nach oben zu deckeln und nämlich
da wo wir ein preisanstieg auf der einen
seite verzeichnen auf der anderen seite
irgendwo eine entlastung schaffen weil
es darf eben nicht passieren dass der
ganze wirklich der durchschnittsbürger
dass menschen sich wirklich nachher
nicht mal mehr die heizung leisten kann
das geht nicht so also ich folge dem
gedanken obwohl ich sehe dass der
grossmann zu einer vehementen gegenrede
schon luft geholt hat ich folge erstmal
dem gedanken und finde auch also wenn
wir jetzt sehen dass praktisch alles was
den menschen spaß macht und alles was
den menschen schmeckt in einer weise
teurer wird dass sie sich kaum mehr
leisten können das also sozusagen die
durch die inflation bei lebensmitteln
sprechen über luxusgüter oder irgendwas
was man haben kann und nicht so ein
dinge die man für den täglichen bedarf
braucht und der große mann kennt sich
damit der wirklich exorbitant gut aus
wenn es also teurer und teurer wird dann
ist es ein direkter griff ein gieriger
griff ins portemonnaie der leute und
meine logik folgt diesem gedanken
dergestalt dass ich sage wenn dem staat
das geld auszugehen droht dann erhöhte
steuern und sinnlos bedeutet das wenn
den menschen das geld auszugehen droht
dann muss er sie senken und mein blick
fällt dabei auf die mehrwertsteuer also
wenn ich auf das deutsche steuersystem
gucke muss ich sagen klar die
rohstoffpreise haben wir nicht im griff
klar die korona folgen haben wir nicht
im griff kann man vielleicht auch hinten
nicht politikern vorwerfen was war beim
griff frauen ist unser eigenes
steuersystem und ich würde der ampel
koalition die ja möglicherweise entsteht
da schon mit in die wiege legen auch
dieses instrument zu spielen und über
eine mehrwertsteuersenkung nachzudenken
damit die menschen mehr geld im
geldbeutel am ende muss ich enttäuschen
werden er steuererhöhungen erleben das
muss sie jetzt ihren
fdp vielleicht aber die die spd in die
grünen die werden auf jeden fall am
steuerrad drehen in den nächsten jahren
weil wir sind doch jetzt schon dass die
wirtschaft weltweit abschwächt wir sehen
dass die schulden explodieren die
kredite müssen bezahlt werden und wie
sie gesagt ich hab die systematik auch
schon ergriffen das gute an politik ist
dass man am schluss immer ein hat das
ist wirklich clevere und noch heraus man
sie auch noch mal sagen noch nie wo die
krise natürlich durch gelddrucken gelöst
das hat man schon in der vergangenheit
oft versucht ist immer geschadet
temporär kann das funktionieren
aber meiner ansicht nach den weg hat
einfach das versagen vor allem der
notenbankpolitik weil das ist auch ein
wichtiger faktor für die inflation die
laxen notenbankpolitik die niedrigen
zinsen und die aufkaufprogramme die
immer mehr geld ins system spielen die
die aktienmärkte immobilienmärkte weiter
aufblähen wer kann sich denn in berlin
noch adäquaten wohnraum leisten oder in
landshut wie kann man noch
altersvorsorge betreiben wenn man immer
schnell im hamsterrad rennen muss aber
nicht auf die seite legen kann bei 4,1
da bringt man schlecht verzinsten
bausparvertrag gar nichts auch keine
lebensversicherer 5 und auf dem konto
kriege ich auch nicht auf mehr
altersarmut lichkeit weil ich schon
völlig hoch bewertet sind das ist eine
richtige blase also da wird eine
altersarmut welle auf uns zukommen die
können wir uns gar nicht sondern sagen
weil man zum beispiel in den letzten
jahrzehnten auf den dax gesetzt hat es
gibt jetzt mal schwer pts/25 euro im
monat weil es hört sich an als wäre die
börse ist hier nur was für reiche das
ist nicht so ich würde eher mal ein
plädoyer dafür halten dass wir auch mal
anders an die geldanlage raumes sind die
deutschen sind viel zu börsen schon
viele wenn man in den dax investiert hat
in den letzten jahren hat man rendite
gemacht der dax ist gestiegen jetzt kann
auch weiterhin so gts sind auch eine
anlage ich finde schwierig ich finde zum
beispiel die aktien rente das ist ja
auch im programm der fdp klien sehr gute
neurologischen punkt wir sehen will ich
da sagen vielleicht müssen einfach unser
angekommen ich glaube wenn wir jetzt die
menschen hab ich mich ändern also
sozusagen wir werden jetzt können jetzt
natürlich die werbetrommel für aktien
und so weiter aber wenn ich jetzt hier
also angenommen ich habe jetzt seit dem
fehlt mir doch mal was ist jetzt so viel
geld komplett fange ich gleich mal an
also wenn man dabei auf was konkret ich
habe ja irgendwie durch irgendeinen
zufall und erst mal alles gut gelaufen
ist habe ich 1000 euro auf das sagt ja
was mache ich mit denen sie zum bewahren
von diesen schrecklichen entwicklungen
nicht bitcoin doch also sagen auch
widersacher pauschal aktien ist richtig
was dort mache nicht umgesetzt also als
erstes kaufe ich mir eure bücher das ist
mir schon klar
das sind schon nur noch 9 und
das erstmal menschen würden mit
wirtschaft für wirtschaft interessieren
und ich habe das gefühl dass ich
menschen vor allem junge menschen
menschen die noch zur schule sich
erstmal für wirtschaft interessieren und
es ist leider so ich greife jetzt nicht
unsere lehrer pauschal an aber ich habe
den eindruck aufgrund meiner
lebenserfahrung dass viele lehrer wenn
nicht die große mehrheit sich nicht so
sehr für wirtschaft interessiert und für
finanzfragen und so weiter mehr für
andere themen und die werden dann auch
an in den schulen gelehrt es gibt einen
weg ein geringes interesse
man sollte sich schon
informieren was macht denn überhaupt
eine basf oder was machen die firmen
aber einfach nur zu sagen kauft keine
fakten wir haben viel zu viele
finanzielle analphabeten jeder
14-jährige doch nicht mit jenen sache
weiter mit seinem smart bereits prozent
retten was ist ein verbot wie es darum
hält die regierung will auch entscheiden
lassen dell geld und finanzen wenig geld
in das ich im alter auch noch was er
aber nicht und die banken daran
verdienen wir werden uns auf
wirtschaftskompetenz
und wer so redet finanzen aber wenn es
um geld um finanzen geht faktor und was
ist wenn ein schulfach geld immer eine
sex ab 1 5 pleite
geld auf ein konto macht keinen sinn
nullzinsphase in station knapp mit 19 1
prozent 4 prozent heißt 50 euro weniger
von den 1000 euro oder könnte aber schon
reifen nicht mal ein beispiel geben ich
hatte vor einiger zeit ein für mich
wenig erfreuliches interview mit dem
spiegel gab gleich eine halbe stunde
aufgewendet um zwei spiegel redakteuren
dass die ich das steuerrecht für
unternehmen zu erklären dass ein
gewisser ich glaube jakob augstein immer
erzählt dass weil doch ungerecht dass
die kapitalertragssteuer nur 25 prozent
beträgt und denn andere müssen 40 oder
45 prozent bezahlen dann habe ich gesagt
dann habe ich gesagt sagen erklärt doch
mal den herrn jakob augstein ja das ist
lassen unternehmen drei verschiedene
steuern seine
körperschaftssteuer bezahlt
gewerbesteuer zeit in der noch die 25
prozent bezahlt das musste auch mal
gesagt wenn die haben dass die beiden
spiegel redakteure die sehr sympathisch
machen und so aber wir haben das nicht
verstanden die wollten das auch gar
nicht verstehen dafür interessieren ja
wahrscheinlich den josefsaal geld den
journalisten bekannte journalisten das
thema geld völlig ausgrenzen ja und dann
haben sie nachher geschrieben im
interview ich hätte geredeten wasserfall
ja ich will jetzt warum ich habe
versucht ihnen das zu aktionären aber
die wollten es gar nicht verstehe ja ein
unternehmen in deutschland muss cup also
eher eine gmbh und eine ag
körperschaftsteuer zahlen gehört stadt
sein und dennoch mal bei aus stadt und
nochmal 25 prozent aber wenn man die
anderen beiden steuer einfach weglässt
weil man irgendwie politik machen will
und eine gewisse freundschaft aufbauen
will oder die zahlen ja nur 25 prozent
dann halte ich das für usn abschluss
noch unter dem motto nein ich lege sie
solches kopf genau als ich mit
diversifizieren wir sehen das nicht
notenbanken unlimitiert geld drucken wir
sehen die staaten machen unlimitiert
schulden also brauchen sie jetzt für ihr
vermögen als eine art lebensversicherung
für die kaufkraft durch natur durch die
mathematik limitierte werde ich nur zum
beispiel in gold indes die notenbanken
haben auch alle gold im portfolio ich
würde in aktien investieren vor allem
muss noch in diesem jahr auf aktien
rohstoff aktien würde ich kaufen weil
auch die haben uns in limitierter 1000
aber schnell ich würde hat sich beim
einkaufen in köln ist nämlich der
ultimative inflationsschutz heute auf
einem allzeithoch wie schon erwähnt wir
werden bis weihnachten wahrscheinlich
noch weiter steigen meiner ansicht nach
und dann würde ich auch gucken grund und
boden diamanten kommt darauf an wie viel
geld sie haben oder eine uhr oder haus
jahr 1000 euro wer dann auf jeden fall
bitcoin silber gold und ein paar aktien
haben sie gerne aber ich gehe trotzdem
contra 1 konnte
jede menge strom
heraus man es schaffen jetzt leider
nicht mehr weil jeder hat hier seine
sendungen weiter
[Musik]